So I actually wrote down some
notes 'cause I'm professional.
Oh, good, good.
I'm glad you wrote
some stuff down 'cause, uh...
Sometimes I want to ask
a question,
and I don't know if it's okay
for interrupting, so...
You know what they call it
when they sing to nothing?
A cappella?
[ Light laughter ]
Right?
That's pretty good
that I got something right.
Yeah.
Doesn't happen that often
for me.
Okay, let me ask you
another one.
Except comedy,
I know, but --
What was Disney's follow-up
to "The Little Mermaid?"
Oh, I have no idea.
I think
it was "Aladdin."
Wow.
Is this called
"Make Todd Feel Stupid?"
[ Laughs ]
No, this --
If it's a new game you guys
are trying to launch,
I'm happy,
but just give me a heads up.
Is that how high you are
right now?
Let's talk about this.
The bringer show,
I wish I would have
been able to, like...
Do you have to pronounce it
that way? "Bring-er?"
The bringer --
The "bring-her"...
The bring-er show.
Bringer.
He said
that he didn't know
what a "bring-er" show
was.
I don't know, Todd.
I don't believe
either of them, really.
Can I tell you something else
I saw that's a little --
Please.
When they both --
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Tell me.
I'm being honest.
All on the table.
Honest as it can get.
Here it is.
You know,
I take these cases seriously.
You,
it's just a big joke.
♪ My name's Big Llou
and I weigh 300 pounds ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ My favorite scenes
in "Temple of Doom" ♪
♪ Are all the ones
with short rounds ♪
[ Sighs ]
That's all I got.
You want to figure out this case
or put a little time into it?
Or...
We have it?
Well, have you made
your decision?
I don't even know
what case we're doing.
Yes, you do.
The guy sang
at the other girl's,
I guess,
jazz club.
Supposed to be
a bringer show.
This --
But I don't know why he would
have the number of $500
in his head
if she's like --
'Cause if
it's a bringer show...
Make her --
So now she has to pay
half of what
she was supposed to pay him.
Yes. Yeah!
See, Todd,
it's not so hard, is it?